Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since Arrow
totally got renewed for season 3 early I thought
it would be fun to talk about the top 5 stories
that they should adapt from the comic books
as well as some of the new characters they
should introduce next...Hint Hint.
Ravager and Jericho.
Just to clarify though, when I say it was
renewed early.
What that means is that most shows don’t
get renewed until after their season is over.
So the fact arrow got picked up again halfway
through it’s season means the CW has a lot
of confidence in it.
Six Seasons and a movie confidence.
ha ha.
And I said it before, but here’s some more
evidence, Caity Lotz is sticking around.
She will be back next season as the canary.
So fear not for her death this year.
I’ll also be doing this same type of top
5 stories video for the flash next week, so
if you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get it.
So first let’s talk about just straight
up comic book titles and then specifically
some cool ways they can change things to make
them fit better..
Number 5 - Road To Jericho.
This featured The Red Hood, jason todd attacking
Speedy and Oliver tries to deal with him and
eventually it turns into one villain after
the other tag teaming him including Deathstroke,
Merlyn, Brick and Constantine.
At the end of the story, he also ends up asking
Black Canary to marry him.
There are a couple aspects of this they could
change.
Because a lot of the batman characters are
tied up legally with Fox’s gotham tv show,
they could use slade’s son Jericho or even
ravager to come after Roy for revenge in the
wake of the season 2 finale.
We don’t know what’s going to happen this
year with Slade’s character, but it will
not end well for him.
He won’t die, but he will be beaten badly.
I think of all the new characters to bring
on next year, his children have been the most
referenced people the past two years that
we’ve never seen.
Bringing them on would be a way in to Young
Justice and eventually Teen Titans.
Number 4 - Archers Quest, who wants to go
on a road trip with oliver?
This story is all about Oliver reclaiming
really sentimental personal items from all
over the world.
Including family heirlooms.
They did a brief team arrow road trip to russia
this season already in a diggle-centric episode,
but it would be a good opportunity for a Roy-Oliver
ramblin’ man story that let’s them travel
outside the city.
Or they could swap the Roy part for Felicity.
Raise your hand if you want to see an Oliver-Felicity
road trip
Them sharing a motel room would cause tumblr
to explode (make noise).
Number 3 - Hard Traveling Heroes, Green Lantern
Crossover anyone?
This is also a road trip story but it’s
also a green lantern crossover.
It’s Oliver, hal Jordan and Black canary
solving problems as they travel through the
midwest jack kerouac style.
The story was originally from the 70s and
is super political, but they could use it
as an opportunity to swap hal jordan for grant
gustin’s flash.
Imagine oliver and barry on a road trip, with
some of the comedy flowing from the fact that
barry is stuck traveling at human speeds in
a jet when he could just run way faster.
It’s unclear how substantial crossovers
are going to be between flash and arrow characters,
but it’s likely that they’ll involve major
villains.
Last year’s arrow road trip was a psuedo
suicide squad story, so oliver could always
get involved in a flash rogues story.
This was also the comic that dealt with Roy’s
heroin addiction.
They kind of already did that with the mirakuru
storyline, but they could still use the serum
as continuing allegory for addiction.
Number 2 - Longbow Hunters.
This is where it starts to get dark.
Longbow actually features an aging Oliver,
which they would have to fudge a bit on, but
he tracks down a serial killer while black
canary tries to take down a drug circle.
It’s the story where Oliver first meets
shado, which they’d have to change just
based on her being dead on the tv show.
The reason it’s super dark is because Oliver
ends up murdering one of the villains he finds
torturing Black Canary.
Arrow kind of did this during season 2 when
count vertigo was going to inject Felicity
with the mirakuru serum.
So technically the tv version of oliver has
already gone into that territory.
Some changes they could make would be again,
swapping the shado character for ravager or
even Sin who should get a slightly expanded
role next year anyway.
They could even swap oliver and black canary’s
roles.
Remember, she’s only just left the league
of assassins, so she hasn’t pacified herself
in the way oliver is trying to this year.
Remember he’s all about not killing people
anymore, but that’s still something Sara
is dealing with.
Number 1 - Cry For Justice.
This is a longshot, but it’s such an epic
story it has to be mentioned.
Oliver basically goes nuts in this story after
Prometheus chops roy’s arm off and eventually
results in the fall of green arrow storyline.
It’s a story about how oliver is undone
as a person after his family and his team
are decimated.
Right now they’re kind of teasing this with
slade’s storyline in present day.
Slade is going to try and destroy oliver’s
life by destroying everything he loves.
What they could do that would be really epic
would be having oliver cross the line a little
going after villains and have amanda waller
send the suicide squad to stop him.
It would be like the government going after
team arrow with their own team of supers.
I don’t think they’ll do a story that
dark, but it would be awesome to see amanda
waller and oliver go after each other.
All that being said, here’s a bonus choice
because arrow has also been borrowing stories
from the batman universe and all over the
greater dc universe.
Kingdom Come.
Think of it as being like a dc version of
days of future past.
You could even involve a practical time travel
aspect to the story via the flash and STAR
LABS technology.
Maybe something more technical than the cosmic
treadmill, but it would just be a story where
you have oliver try to prevent a much darker
timeline from actually happening.
It would even be a way to kill a major character
like Felicity or Thea or even Oliver himself.
And then fix everything by the end as if nothing
bad ended up happening.
Now it’s your turn, which DC story do you
want to see arrow do next year.
Next week I’m going to do my top 5 new characters
arrow should introduce.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Don’t forget, valentines day I’m posting
Hannibal season 2 and supernatural season
10 videos.
it’s going to be a fun weekend.
Right now click here to learn all about the
arrow flash crossover that’s happening this
year and click here for my arrow Q&A.
Thanks for watching, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!